I LIKE TO CALL THE MARCH SIXTH.
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING TO ORDER.
AND IF WE CAN.
HAVE A CALL THE OVER THE WALL
[inaudible]
KALRA HERE [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BONTA REPEATS.
THANK YOU AND SO WE'RE GONNA --
NOW THAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM -- A
COUPLE OF A HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS.
THE OTHER SHE THAT THERE IS.
OKAY SO TODAY --
ETCETERA BONTA IT WILL BE WHEN
HE ARRIVES --
REPLACING SOME MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
AT THE REQUEST TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE COMMISSION THE SPEAKER
OF TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
AND FOR TODAY.
THE BILL IS BEING HEARD TODAY
WILL STILL BE SIX MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE THEY CAN HAVE TWO
WITNESSES THREE WITNESSES BUT
SIX MASS IS THE TOTAL TIME AND
SO THEY CAN.
DIVIDE UP THE WAY THAT THEY
CHOOSE AND SO FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ASK THERE'S A MOTION TO ADOPT A
COMMITTEE RULES.
SECOND ACT OUT ON THE FUNDING TO
ROLL CALL VOTE [inaudible]
KALRA I FLORA [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
THREE OF US.
OKAY SO THE RULES YES THE RULES
ARE ADOPTED.
AND A SIMILAR GONZALEZ WHICH WAS
LIKE A START.
I ALWAYS GET ON THE LINE.
WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS AB --
FIFTY ONE AUTHORED BY OUR VERY
OWN ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR --
MEMBERS AB FIFTY ONE IS SHOULD
NOT BE TOO NEW TO YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE PROBABLY SEEN THIS IN THE
PAST AS WE ALL VOTED ON IT LAST
YEAR AS WELL.
THANK YOU --
I JUST A REMINDER THAT OUR
LEGISLATURE HIS --
PAST SOME OF THE STRONGEST
WORKER PROTECTIONS IN THE
COUNTRY BUT WHEN WORKERS ARE
FORCED -- TO
SIGN BINDING ARBITRATION AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO UTILIZE THOSE LAWS
THAT WE PUT IN PLACE EITHER
THROUGH --
COURT ACTION --
THROUGH FEE HOW.
AS SUCH ISSUES SUCH AS PAY
INEQUITY SEXUAL HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION RETALIATION AGREE
JUST LABOR VIOLATIONS LIKE WAGE
DEALT IN SECRET BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS --
WITHOUT THE RIGHT TO APPEAL.
SO IT'S TIME THAT WE TAKE ON
THIS ISSUE OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
MOVEMENT ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO
START TO LOOK AT THIS BUT WE
CAN'T WAIT FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ACT AND WE MUST
ARE TAKING ON NOW --
WITH ME TODAY I'D IS CAITLYN
VEGA WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
AND SHANE --
BUT THE TEAMSTERS.
SHANE WHAT'S THE LAST DATE.
GUSMAN OF COURSE.
HEY AT LEAST IN ITS FIRST NAME
RIGHT.
BEFORE WE GO ON HOW IT IS RIGHT
HERE GLASS MEANT THAT AND BEHALF
OF TEAMSTERS AG AFTER CALTRAIN
CONTENTS OF MACHINISTS.
ATO UNITE HERE.
OKAY RIGHT BEFORE THE WHOLE ON
TO THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
ONCE AGAIN --
WITNESSES TOTAL SIX MINUTES
TWENTY THREE AND THREE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO USE UP ALL THE TIME YOU
WANT.
TO AND THERE IS A A MOTION BY
SUMMER CARILLO TO MOVE THE BILL
ALL SECOND IT.
AND WE'LL GO ON WITH OUR
WITNESSES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION PROUD SPONSORS OF AB.
FIFTY ONE AND WE HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FORCED ARBITRATION FOR
MANY YEARS PARTICULARLY AS WE
HAVE SEEN ITS RAPID GROWTH.
IN WORKPLACES OF LOW WAGE
WORKERS AND SO INITIALLY THIS
STARTED AS SOMETHING THAT MAYBE
WOULD BE NEGOTIATED WITH VERY
HIGH WAGE PROFESSIONALS.
IT IS NOW SOMETHING THAT APPEARS
SINCE FOR FAST FOOD JOBS YOU
HAVE TO WAIVE ALL RIGHTS WHETHER
IT'S DISCRIMINATION SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WAGE THEFT YOU CANNOT
GO TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER TO
HAVE YOUR CLAIM ADJUDICATED.
YOU CANNOT GO TO COURT YOU
CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN A
COLLECTIVE ACTION YOU ARE STUCK
IN THE PRIVATE ARBITRATION
SYSTEM SET UP AND PAID FOR BY
YOUR ABUSER.
THIS IS NOT AN ACCEPTABLE SYSTEM
THIS IS NOT JUSTICE --
WE ARE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT WE
ASK FOR YOUR I FELT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS THE SAG AFTRA
THE AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
MACHINISTS.
I HAVE P. T. LOCALS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THE UTILITY
WORKERS UNION OF AMERICA --
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- AS
MISS VEGAS STATED WE ALL HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON THIS
ISSUE SUPPORTING NEEDS MEASURES
AS I HAVE COME THROUGH LAST
YEAR'S BILL MR HERNANDEZ'S BILL.
THE PROBLEM IS STILL OUT THERE
AND IS GROWING --
IN ALMOST EVERY INDUSTRY FOLKS
ARE USING THESE AGREEMENTS AND
AND LET LET'S BE CLEAR THEY'RE
USING THEM NOT TO SIMPLY SAVE
MONEY AND QUARTER YOU SENT TO
UNDERMINE THE SUBSIDY OF LAWS
THAT YOU GUYS ALL PASS --
DATE THERE FOR FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T SPECIFY WHICH
LAWS YOU'RE WAVING BECAUSE YOU
DON'T GET --
TO JOINED TOGETHER WITH YOUR
FELLOW EMPLOYEES THE ABILITY TO
FIND A LAWYER TO REPRESENT YOU
IS UNDERMINED --
AND THESE ARE SECRET --
BEHAVIOR AFTERWARDS EVEN IF YOU
WIN THE EMPLOYER GETS TO KEEP ON
DOING THE SAME CONDUCT WITH NO --
NO PENALTY SO WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND WE URGE ITS PASSAGE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO QUOTE PROUD BECAUSE
SPONSORS AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY ANGER IN A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DB SELLING BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN
PLUMMET LAWYERS JUST ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AS BROWN SEVEN THICK ON BEHALF
OF RESTAURANT OPPORTUNITIES
CENTER IS UNITED AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MANDY BENSON CO FOUNDER OF WORK
EQUITY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH BUT DOWNEY I AT THE
LOCAL FIFTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JOHN KELLY IOTTIE LOCAL FIFTY IS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JERMAINE JACKSON PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AS IDEAS ON
BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE MEDIA WHAT ON BEHALF THAT
THE LOTUS WHAT THE FOUNDATION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ALSO SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARC CURTIS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TESTIFIED TODAY WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB.
FIFTY ONE AGAIN THIS IS THE BILL --
FROM LAST YEAR IT WAS A JOB
KILLER IT IS BEEN TAGGED AS A
JOB FOR THIS YEAR THE INTENT AND
FOCUS OF THE BILL IS TO
ELIMINATE ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS
FOR LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
DISPUTES.
SIGNED AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT PROHIBITS ANY
STATE STATUTE THAT LIMITS
PROHIBITS OR INTERFERES WITH THE
RIGHT TO ARBITRATION.
THE LIMITATION PROHIBITION FROM
FORMATION OF AN ARBITRATION.
AGREEMENT AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT HAS ALREADY BEEN
DEEMED TO BE PREEMPTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COURT OF APPEALS IT'S
A HOLY VERSES WHITE MEMORIAL
CENTER AND JUSTICE KAGAN WHO WAS
APPOINTED BY BARACK OBAMA ALSO
STATED IN CANDOR NURSING CENTERS
THAT THE FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT
APPLIES NOT ONLY TO CONTRACTS.
ONCE THEIR FORM BUT ALSO HOUSE
HOLLY THE COURT WAS EVALUATING
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN THAT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND PROHIBIT AN
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT REQUIRED.
AS A CONDITION OF A CONSUMER
CONTRACT FOR THE RESOLUTION OF
SPECIFIC CIVIL RIGHT CLAIMS THE
COURT STATED THAT THE SPECIAL
RESTRICTION ON THE FORMATION OF
THE CONTRACT WAS PREEMPTED BY
THE FAA.
AS A PLACE CONTRACTUAL
RESTRICTIONS ON ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS ARE NOT REQUIRED BALK
REMAINS GOVERNOR BROWN STAGE IN
HIS VETO MESSAGE THAT A NEARLY
IDENTICAL BILL PLAINLY VIOLATED
FEDERAL LAW.
ADDING PROPOSED SECTION TO AB
FIFTY ONE THAT SEATS NOTHING IN
THIS LAW EXPANDS UPON THE BASIS
TO CHALLENGE A CONTRACT LAWFULLY
CREATED DOES NOT SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AS IT STILL SEEKS TO
INTERFERE WITH THE FORMATION OF
AN ARBITRATION AGREEMENT.
WHICH IS PREEMPTED UNDER FEDERAL
LAW.
JUST LIKE AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX SEVENTEEN THIS BILL WILL BE
CHALLENGE AND GO THROUGH
LITIGATION WHICH IS NOT SERVE
THE EMPLOYEE OR THE EMPLOYER
ONLY THE TRIAL ATTORNEYS.
AS DRAFTED AB FIFTY ONE ALSO
PROHIBIT SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
AND ADDS A NEW CAUSE OF ACTION
UNDER THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING ACT WILL EACH WILL
INVITE FURTHER LITIGATION THANKS.
THANK YOU IT'S ABOUT FOUR
MINUTES FOR THE TWO OF YOU CAN
DIVIDE IT UP.
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO THE
REMAINING WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM STONE STONE
ADVOCACY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION --
ARBITRATION IS A FAIR --
AND IT MEANS OF RESOLVING
DISPUTES THAT HAS BEEN UP HELD
BY A CALIFORNIA COURSE AND BY
FEDERAL COURTS.
AND THERE IS NOT --
IT'S YOU --
SAY LAWS AND MUST BE FOLLOWED IN
ARBITRATION AND MANY OF PEOPLE
WHO GO THROUGH ARBITRATION FIND
THAT THE QUICKER AND LESS FORMAL
NATURE OF IT ACTUALLY MAKES THEM
FEEL LIKE THEY GOT THEIR DAY IN
COURT EVEN THOUGH THE IN GET
THEIR DAY IN COURT IT WAS THEIR
DAY IN.
ARBITRATION --
AND THERE ARE --
OUR ARBITRATION IS ALSO --
MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE.
AND DONE IN A QUICKER WAY AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE THE
BILL ENERGY TO VOTE NOW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MISTER CHAIR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION ANOTHER
CLIENTS I WANT TO CONGRATULATE
YOUR NEW CHIEF CONSULTANT ON A
PROMOTION.
A COUPLE OF QUICK POINTS TO NOTE
ONE IS.
A PROPONENTS MADE THE CLAIM THAT
THIS IS BEING PAID FOR BY THE
ABUSE OR THE EMPLOYER.
THAT IS DUE TO A CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT DECISION WHICH
REQUIRES THE IN EMPLOYMENT
ONTEXT IN EMPLOYMENT
ARBITRATION FOR THE EMPLOYER TO
PAY ALL OF THOSE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ARBITRATION.
A SECRET PROCEEDINGS DUE TO
LEGISLATION --
BY THEN ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY CHAIR
BOB WHAT CAO SKI REQUIRES A
QUARTERLY PUBLICATION BY ALL THE
ARBITRATION COMPANIES.
AND SO WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE ARE OF DISPUTE THE AMOUNT
THAT WAS AWARDED WHO WON WHO
LOST IT CETERA THAT HAS TO BE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON THERE ARE
ON THEIR WEBSITE SO WE KNOW A
LOT MORE ABOUT.
ARBITRATION AND IN MANY OTHER
STATES AND THE CLAIM AS HAS BEEN
MADE YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT IS
THAT WERE UNDERMINING
SUBSTANTIVE LAWS.
JUST BECAUSE YOU SIGNED AN
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT DOESN'T
MEAN WE CAN CHANGE THE
UNDERLYING LAW WHERE EMPLOYERS
DID ATTEMPT TO DO IT FOR EXAMPLE
SHORTENING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT THROWN OUT
WHERE THERE WAS A CAP OR
PROHIBITION ON PUNITIVE DAMAGES
THROWN OUT.
JUST BECAUSE THERE'S AN
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT DOESN'T
MEAN ALL OF A SUDDEN THAT I
COULD -- PAY
SOMEBODY LESS THAN THE MINIMUM
WAGE OR ELIMINATE ANY OTHER
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHTS ARBITRATION
IS A VENUE IT DOESN'T AFFECT
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN YOUR EFFORTS TO
BUTTER UP MY CHIEF CONSULTANT AS
NOTED -- ANY
OTHER ANY OTHER A OF FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON OCCURRED WITH IDLE STINK
GILBERT ROBESON AND SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN STAFFING
ASSOCIATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
STAFFING PROFESSIONALS.
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSE FOR
ALL THE REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
RETURN MEMBERS MIKE BELOW FOR
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAW
COUNCIL OPPOSED THANK YOU.
OKAY SO THAT'S A WE DO HAVE A
MOTION --
ALREADY A TO MOVE THE BILL THE
BILL -- AND
YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND AND
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
HI WE US WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
SERVICE WAS ALSO --
I'LL CLOSE BY SAYING.
THIS HASN'T BEEN DETERMINED
EXISTING ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS
WE JUST ONE ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS TO ACTUALLY BE
VOLUNTARILY ENTERED INTO WE
DON'T THINK ARBITRATION IS
NECESSARILY BAD.
I'M COMING FROM LABOR MOVEMENT
WE ACTUALLY OF SUPPORTED
ARBITRATION --
BINDING ARBITRATION.
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IS --
THE FACTS THAT WE KNOW --
AND TODAY IT'S KIND OF FUNNY
THAT WERE ARGUE ABOUT WHETHER
WHY EMPLOYERS PAY FOR
ARBITRATION AND WERE SEEN ON THE
NEWS THAT SOME EMPLOYERS IN FACT.
CHOOSE NOT TO PAY FOR
ARBITRATION AS A WAY TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE WORKERS DON'T EVEN
HAVE THEIR DAY IN ARBITRATION SO
WHAT USED TO BE USED AS A WAY TO
AVOID -- AT
TRUE SCRUTINY FOR THE EMPLOYER
THERE NOW JUST SIMPLY REFUSING
TO EVEN ENGAGE IN OR THEY DON'T
ENGAGE IN TIMELY ARBITRATION SO.
THAT WE WE WE SEE KIND OF THE
DOWNWARD SPIRAL ON WHERE EVEN --
WORKERS AT GOOGLE HAVE FORCED
THE COMPANY TO STOP USING THESE
AGREEMENTS I I THINK THE WORLD
IS CHANGING AS WE SEE IT AND I
THINK IT'S TIME --
THAT THIS BILL IS PASSED AND
SIGNED WE DO HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR
AND SO WERE WHO WERE HELPFUL FOR
A FRESH SET OF EYES ON THIS
ISSUE -- I I
JUST WITH THAT HI --
I WOULD THERE WAS ONE THING I
THINK WHEN I FOUND OUT THAT WAS
THE MOST COMPELLING REASON.
WHY AT ARBITRATION CANNOT?
REALLY SATISFY --
A WORKERS CLAIMS.
AND I WAS VERY I WAS SHOCKED BY
THIS WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
SO.
YES AN ARBITRATION AGREEMENT
SELF CAN'T CAN'T WAIVE CERTAIN
RIGHTS BUT ONCE IN ARBITRATION
IF THE ARBITRATOR GETS THE WALL
WRONG IF THEY'RE JUST SIMPLY
WRONG THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO WAY
TO APPEAL THAT.
THAT THEY JUST SAT EVEN IF THE
ARBITRATORS BEEN FOUND IT TO
HAVE DISCRIMINATED GETS A WORKER
THERE'S NOTHING THAT CAN BE DONE
AND I THINK IN OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN THE WAY WE LOOK AT THE
WORLD.
THAT THERE SHOULD ALWAYS BE A
CORRECTIONS THAT ARE MADE ARE
OFTEN MADE IN COURT OF LAW THERE
IS -- OFTEN
MADE THROUGH ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES --
WE WE VALUE THAT RIGHT TO APPEAL
THAT GETS TAKEN AWAY IN A SECRET
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT --
AND SO TODAY I JUST ASK YOU ONCE
AGAIN -- TO
BUT I ON THIS BILL.
OKAY WELL THERE IS A A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL BY SUMMER CARILLO
SECOND BY THE CHAIR AND THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIRS
AND I A PIECE OF CAN TAKE A LOOK.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
FLORA.
FLORA NO CREO.
REAL I'D DEEP GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I BONTA.
REVERSE.
REVERSED HI THAT THE THE BILL IS
OUT AND WILL.
THROW OPEN FOR MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT --
AND SUMMER BECAUSE TO PRESENT
BILLS AND WE'LL GET BACK TEARS
YOU HAVE TO BE --
ANYWAY RIGHT.
AND LOOKS LIKE FIRST UP IS A
AB.
THREE THREE THREE JOHN WHEN I
CAN REMEMBER.
THREE AND SO --
ETCETERA EGGMAN --
PRIOR.
TO COMING TO REMAIN SOCIALLY
SAID SIX MINUTES TOTAL FOR
WITNESSES YOU CAN.
DIVIDE IT UP ANYWAY YOU'D LIKE
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THIS IS GOING
TO HAVE TO GIVE ALL THE TIME IS
UP TO TO THEM INTO YOU GUYS WANT
TO PUT THAT OUT THERE.
AS WELL AS FOR MR SALAS WAS
GOING TO BE COMING UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
THIS BILL MAY SEEM FAMILIAR
BECAUSE WE DID SINCE THE THAT
LAST YEAR AND IT MADE IT ALL THE
WAY TO THE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK -- AND
HE VETOED IT SO WE ARE BACK THIS
YEAR WITH THE NEW GOVERNOR AND
WE FEEL LIKE THIS IS BECOMING AN
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THIS BILL TENDS.
HOPES TO EXTEND WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTION TO CONTRACTED
EMPLOYEES WHOSE ROLES INVOLVED
RECEIVING AND INVESTIGATING
COMPLAINTS.
SO WE HAVE PATIENT RIGHTS
ADVOCATES OUT THERE OFTENTIMES
THEY DON'T WORK FOR THE FACILITY
THEY ARE CONTRACTED TO SOMEBODY
ELSE ARE COMING IN TO INSPECT --
AND THEY DON'T HAVE ANY RIGHTS
MOST OF THE THE LAWS THAT WE
PASS. TO PROTECT WHISTLEBLOWERS
THAT IS SEEN AS SO THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO'S COMING OUTSIDE
OFTENTIMES CONTRACTED OR
NONPROFIT COMING IN --
SO THIS JUST EXTENT ESSEX TO
EXTEND THOSE RIGHTS. TO
CONTRACTED EMPLOYEES OR EVEN
VOLUNTEERS WHO ARE COMING IN --
TO TO LOOK AFTER OUR MOST
VULNERABLE.
AND I HAVE TO WITNESSES HERE
WITH ME.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE THREE THREE MY NAME IS
SAMUEL JAN AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES
WE ARE THE PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING COUNTY
PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND
ARE CO SPONSORS OF AB.
THREE THREE THREE STATE LAW
REQUIRES THAT EVERY COUNTY HAVE
A DESIGNATED PATIENTS RIGHTS
OFFICE TO RECEIVE AND
INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS OF
ALLEGED PATIENTS RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AND MONITOR LOCKED
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH PATIENTS RIGHTS
LAWS.
WE SEE HORRIBLE THINGS
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF OUR OUR
OUR JOB.
INCLUDING GROW CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS.
AND PATIENT DEATHS FROM NEGLECT
TO MISTREATMENT.
OUR WORK IS CRITICAL TO
IMPROVING CONDITIONS AND QUALITY
OF CARE WITHIN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM.
HOWEVER OUR PROFESSION HAS BEEN
PLAGUED WITH INSTANCES OF
RETALIATION RESULTING IN FEAR
AMONGST ADVOCATES THAT THEY MAY
LOSE THEIR POSITION FOR
CONDUCTING THEIR STATUTORY
DUTIES.
APPROXIMATELY 50% OF PATIENTS
RIGHTS ADVOCATES ARE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS OR EMPLOYEES OF A
CONTRACTED AGENCY.
UNLIKE COUNTY EMPLOYEES THESE
CONTRACTED ADVOCATES DO NOT HAVE
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS.
OUR DUTIES MAY REQUIRE US TO
INFORM STATE LICENSING.
ABOUT SERIOUS PATIENTS RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AT A COUNTY FACILITY
WHICH ARE COUNTY MAY FROWNED
UPON.
ADVOCATES HAVE HAD THEIR
CONTRACT NOT RENEWED IN THE
CONTEXT OF FORWARDING A PATIENT
COMPLAINT TO LICENSING.
AB THREE THREE THREE WOULD
EXTEND ALREADY EXISTING
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS FOR
EMPLOYEES TO CONTRACTORS IN A
WATCHDOG ROLE.
THESE WOULD APPLY TO OTHER
CONTRACTED ORGANIZATIONS
RECEIVING AN INVESTIGATING
COMPLAINTS INCLUDING THOSE
WORKING WITH INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
FOSTER HOME CHILDREN ARE ELDERLY
AN INDEPENDENT PLEASE CITED A
PROGRAMS.
AB THREE THREE THREE IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THE PROFESSIONS PROTECTING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE ARE ABLE TO
CONDUCT THEIR JOB WITHOUT FEAR
FOR IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK WE ACTUALLY DO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE THE THIRD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
SHOT ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH PLANNING COUNCIL IN THE
PAST CHAIR OF THE PATIENT RIGHTS
COMMITTEE OF THAT COUNCIL.
I AM ALSO --
ACTUALLY CONSTITUENTS OF OF THE
SEGMENTS.
OF WE ALSO CO SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL AND AS MENTIONED --
HAD WENT THROUGH THIS LAST YEAR
MANDATED BY STATUTE TO ADVISE ON
POLICIES AND PRACTICES THAT
AFFECT PATIENT RIGHTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ARE
COMMITTEE CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF
PATIENT RIGHTS ADVOCATE PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE --
OF RECEIVED AN OVER 50% RESPONSE
TO THE SURVEY AND IT UP IN
REPRESENTED THIRTY ONE COUNTIES.
NEARLY A FIFTH OF THE EMPLOYEES
CONTACT.
UP EMPLOYEES OF CONTRACTED
AGENCIES INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
CITED CONCERN OVER LOSING THEIR
CONTRACT AS A FACTOR AFFECTING
HOW STRONGLY THEY ADVOCATE
AGAINST PRACTICES AND POLICIES
THEY BELIEVE VIOLATE THEIR
CLIENTS RIGHTS.
THIS IS A COURSE OF SERIOUS
CONCERN TO US AS AFFECTS HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY CAN BE IN THEIR
JOB. ONE SURVEY RESPONDENTS
STATED HERE IS NO A TANAMI OR
PROTECTION FROM ADMINISTRATORS
THAT MAY SEE YOU AS AN ADVERSARY
OR THORN IN THEIR SIDE.
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR
CAN CHOOSE TO DIVERT OR SILENCE
THE EFFORTS OF AN ADVOCATE AT
ANY TIME.
ALL OF US ARE SUBJECT TO
UNCHECKED REPERCUSSIONS IF WE
RUFFLED WRONG FEATHERS.
AND AS SAM YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME INSTANCES
OF PATIENT RIGHTS ADVOCATES WHO
DID NOT HAVE THEIR CONTRACTS
RENEWED BECAUSE THEY ADVOCATED.
A VERY STRONGLY FOR THEIR CLIENT.
WE BELIEVE THAT AB THREE THIRTY
THREE WILL PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
PROTECTION TO PATIENT RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND THE OTHER
PROFESSIONS THAT SAMUEL HAS
MENTIONED.
THAT ARE IN SIMILAR WITH.
WATCHDOG ROLES AND WILL ALLOW
THEM TO DO THEIR JOBS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH BUT ANY
ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
JACKETS ARE NOT MAY HAVE THE
CONSUMER TWENTY CALIFORNIANS
TRANSPORT. TO HOLD ON ONE MOMENT
WILL GET THE MICROPHONE ON YEAH
THANK YOU.
WHEN ANY CELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU?
DOES THIS TENDER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE KEY WHEN ALL IN CURTEA SEEM
LIKE A GOOD IDEA AT THE TIME --
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE STATEWIDE
CONTRACT --
FOR PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCACY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
IS COMMITTED.
ANDREY RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OKAY --
SO THIS BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THERE IS A MOTION ON
THE TABLE OF FROM SIMMER CARILLO
SECOND BY SUMMER GONZALEZ ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SOME REGULARS LIKE CLOTHES I
JUST RESPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TO HELP US PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING
BACK THIS BILL AGAIN THERE IS A
RECOMMENDATION BY FROM THE CHAIR
AS WITH ENGLAND APRIL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE A FLORA.
FLORA I AGREE YOU.
CARILLO I DEEP.
BY THE AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I BONTA REVERSED.
PREVIOUS AYE THE BILL ITSELF.
THOSE ARE.
THE MOVE ON TO APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
I'M REAR END BILL SIGN ORDER
THAT SAYS SIMILAR RAY IS --
DEFERRING WHILE [inaudible]
YES.
THE YOU YOU OVER NOW.
THE SERVICE SALAS PLEASE --
ANYBODY HERE WHO --
IS I'LL MAKE THIS BRIEF
INDIFFERENCE.
TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN WHO
ALLOWED ME.
TO SUPERSEDE OR AB TWO OR THREE
WOULD HELP IMPROVE WORKER SAFETY
AS IT RELATES TO VALLEY FEVER BY
REQUIRING CONSTRUCTION.
EMPLOYERS IN ENDEMIC COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE EFFECTIVE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION TRAINING FOR EMPLOYEE.
UP ANYWAY THIS IS A SPORT.
A LOWER CREDIT HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT DOES
PROVIDE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
TO THESE EMPLOYEES WHICH WE
THINK IS A GREAT.
ASSET TO UTILIZE AND WEEKEND WE
ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU.
I ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CAPTION YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS KATE ON WHO DROWNED WITH
STATE COUNCIL LABORS ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
pON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- WILL
BRING BACK ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THERE IS A MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BY SUMMER CARILLO
SECONDED BY SUMMER GONZALEZ.
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA.
FLORA I CARILLO.
CREEL AYE DEEP HI DEEP I AND
SALAS.
GONZALEZ I BONTA.
REVERSE.
REVERSED HI.
I'D BILLS OUT THANK YOU SENATOR
SALAS WERE.
KEEPING YOUR WORD AND HAVING A
BRIEF PRESENTATION.
OUT OF RESPECT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES.
A SUMMER REYES LINE ITEM ONE A.
B..
NINE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AND AND YES I SOME REPAIRS --
BUT I THINK I MENTIONED TO YOU
WHEN YOU CAME IN YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD OF WITH A SIX MINUTE TOTAL
FOR WHAT IT SAYS COULD BE
DIVVIED UP ANY WAY YOU CHOOSE.
I PRESENT TO YOU AB NINE TO
SHARE ACT THE STOP HARASSMENT OF
REPORTING EXTENSION ACT WHICH
WILL EXTEND THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS FROM ONE YEAR TO
THREE YEARS. TO FILE A
HARASSMENT CLAIM.
WITH US TO TESTIFYING.
OUR WLS SANDERS AND HER ATTORNEY
TONY HAD A MEAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TONY ARMENIA AND I AM
VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE GIVING
ME AND MY CLIENT GABI STANDARDS
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
TODAY AS TO WHY.
THE ONE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATION IN WHICH TO FILE A
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
CLAIM UNDER OUR LAWS THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT IS MUCH
TOO SHORT.
A VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT ME BECAUSE
I'M GONNA PASS MY TIME TO MY
CLIENT -- I
AM A AN EMPLOYMENT ATTORNEY IN
LOS ANGELES AND I HAVE
REPRESENTED HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA WORKERS IN CLAIMS OF
DISCRIMINATION.
AND HARASSMENT CLAIMS
PARTICULARLY SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND ASSAULTS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE ALSO
HAD TO TURN AWAY MANY CLIENTS
WHO HAD RIGHTEOUS CLAIMS OF
EGREGIOUS ACTS OF DISCRIMINATION
AND HARASSMENT AND FAILURE TO
PROMOTE BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER
OR THEIR RACE THEIR RELIGION.
THEIR DISABILITY BECAUSE THEY
BECAME PREGNANT AND I'VE HAD TO
TURN AWAY BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
KNOW THEIR RIGHTS AND THAT THEY
ONLY HAD ONE YEAR AND WHICH TO
FILE A CLAIM WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING IN
ORDER TO SEEK JUSTICE.
AND SO WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT AND
TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB --
NINE LOTS OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
COMING FORWARD IN LIGHT OF THE
BECAUSE THERE HAVE BEEN
EMBOLDENED TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS AND TO COME
FORWARD AND TALK TO AN ATTORNEY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THEY CAME TOO
LATE AND SO I'M GONNA PASS IT ON
TO MY CLIENT GABBY WHO'S GOING
TO TALK ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO HER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MEETING.
MY NAME IS TO RELAX SANDERS AND
I AM FROM FROM WHEN I CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE.
ARE TO TALK ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE
FOR WORK WHY WE SHOULD EXTEND
THE DEADLINE --
TO FILE A COMPLAINT FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
AND DISCRIMINATION IN THE
WORKPLACE.
I'M A SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO I
WORK IN THE MALE.
DOMINATED INDUSTRY OFFENDING
ATHA ELECTRICIAN TOURNEY.
EIGHTEEN WORKING MY WAY TO
BECOME AN ELECTRICIAN.
OUR CERTIFICATE THIRTY FIVE I
HAVE BEEN TRAINING FOR THREE AND
A HALF YEARS. FOR VERY LARGE
ELECTRICAL ENGINEERING COMPANY
EMPLOYEES TAL PHASE OF
CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
ON FRIDAY IN --
WARRING JOB THE FLOORS WAY I
EQUIPMENT.
CERTAINLY A MARK A MALE COWORKER --
GRAMMY IN A START DRAGGING ME
TOO I MEAN IF YOU ARE URINATE I
DROPPED WHAT I WAS HOLDING TO
PUSH HIM AWAY.
AND HE WAS DRIVING.
MY BRAVE THING.
PRIVATE PARTS I TRIED TO SCREAM.
ANOTHER CALL WORKERS ARE. FOR MY
COMPANY INCLUDING MY SUPERVISOR --
ARE RIGHT DID YOU JUST TO THERE
AND WATCH WHAT HE WAS DOING BUT
NOT NOBODY WAS TRYING TO HELP ME
DOING ANYTHING. ONE OF MY FEMALE
COWORKERS --
FULL HERE WHEN I WITH THIS
CREAMY AND SHE WAS TRYING TO
HELP ME TO TAKE HIM AWAY FROM ME.
SOMEHOW WE ARE.
HE FELL ON THE FLOOR IN A WITH
TRYING TO LEAVE AND THEN HE
CALLED ME FOR ONE MY LEG SENDING.
OUR CALL TO ONE OF MY COWORKERS
BY NAMING HE HELP US TO TAKE HIM
AWAY FROM. FOR ME IN THE IN MY
SUPERVISOR WAS SAYING THAT YOU
WERE GOING TO GET IT WE WERE
GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE THAT WAS
THE ONLY THING HE WAS SAYING BUT
HE DIDN'T EVEN.
HELP OR ANYTHING --
AFTER DOT LIKE EVERYBODY LEFT
LIKE NOTHING HOP IN IN IN.
A WITH THEIR JOBS.
IT'S CARE DISORIENTED AND THEN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
SO -- THE
FOLLOWING MORNING THE FOLLOWING.
MONDAY WHEN I WENT TO WORK --
I TRIED TO TALK TO MY
SUPERINTENDENT --
HE WORKS.
HE WAS CAN I BRUSH ME OFF HE
DIDN'T REALLY TALK TO ME WANTED
TO TALK TO ME AND NOW I'M.
IN I TRY TO BRING THIS SUBJECT
SO MANY TIMES BUT THEY DIDN'T
CARE.
IN ACTUALLY I WENT TO TALK TO
ARM. TO THE SAFETY OFFERS
OFFICER OF THE OF THE MAIN ARM
CONTRACTOR.
IN HIS STATE AND I ASKED HIM IF
HE CAN AND TALKED ARE.
A BOTH SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THE
NEXT MEETING HE SAID HE WAS
GOING TO DO IT BUT HE NEVER DID.
SO -- I
START BRINGING THE SUBJECT UP
BECAUSE THERE WERE TALKING ABOUT
LATE ENOUGH PEOPLE IN.
I DON'T WANT TO BE LAID UP SO.
I JUST CANNOT STOP TALKING ABOUT
IT WITHOUT ANY REFLECTION.
FIFTH ARMED.
THERE WERE LIKE. FOUR HUNDRED
SINCE THE DOOR LIKE --
FOUR HUNDRED EMPLOYEES IN ONLY
SINGLE ARM.
THE GOAL.
A PERSON THERE WERE IN WE WERE
MOMENT.
SO I WAS.
I WAS JUST.
I WAS JUST HAVING A HARD TIME.
BUT I WILL IN NO ARE YOU ALSO
WITH DEALING WITH DEPRESSION AT
SAME TIME BECAUSE OF SINGLE
MINDED I COULDN'T TAKE TIME OFF.
AND GO THROUGH MY TO CHARACTER --
TO RB HOW ARE WE I MEAN TALKING
TO IT I'M THIRTY MINUTES INTO
THE SHOW.
OR WHAT WHAT'S GOING TO WORK
FEELING SAFE EVERY DAY AMONG
OTHER YOU SHOES.
OUR PHONE.
TWO MONTHS LATER THAT I ALSO
DISCOVERED THAT I WITH NO MEAN
BABY OVERLY RATE.
THE MAN WEARING YOUR WAVE FOR
DOING THE SAME JOB.
I DON'T KNOW MY RIGHT.
I FIND I DON'T WANT TO OR NOT
ATTORNEY TO DESCRIBE MY RIGHTS
AND I DO KNOW THAT HIGH JUST
MEANS THE ONE YEAR.
FILL IN DEADLINE FOR MY CHECK
FOR ON THE CLAIM.
WHERE YEAR IS JUST TOO SHORT OF
THE TIME?
I'M ENSURING THIS WITH YOU OFFER
WOMAN WHO PRACTICE DURING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
AND DISCRIMINATION.
IT TAKES A LOT OF COURAGE IN
TIME. TO OVERCOME OUR FEARS OVER
TO BE UNLOCKED.
APPEARS TO BE IN.
FIVE HER FIRST --
COWORKERS ANGRY. FOR ASKING TO
HAVE SEXUAL CURRENTLY IN
TRAINING.
AND TO HAVE TO THE WOMAN TO HELP
MAKE YOU SHORT THERE ARE
MENTALLY HEALTHY FROM WHAT
YOU'RE GOING SO I CAN GO TO WORK
YOU CAN BE THERE FOR THEM OF
THEIR MOM.
SO I ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL NYE EXTENDING
TO START TWO TO THREE YEARS WILL
LOW PEOPLE.
MY NEED TO FIX YOUR FAITH.
THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THE COURAGE TO SPEAK.
SO VERY PUBLICLY ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY PERSONAL --
THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATED THANK
YOU.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE ALSO PROP COSPONSOR OF
THIS MEASURE.
I WOULD JUST REITERATE THAT MOST
PEOPLE DO NOT KNOW WHAT A
STATURE LIMITATIONS IS OR TIME
BAR ON A CLAIM --
WHEN THESE TYPES OF THINGS
HAPPEN TO YOU'RE NOT THINKING
YOU KNOW I HAVE A YEAR?
AND SO AND A LOT OF OTHER
STATUTES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LONGER FOR EXAMPLE A COLLECTION
HERE FOUR YEARS OR A CONTRACT
DISPUTE YOU HAVE FOR YEARS.
SO THESE THE NATURE OF THESE
TYPES OF CLAIMS WARRANT A
MODERNIZATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU --
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES WERE ALSO
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL WE
HAVE MANY WORKERS MOSTLY LOW
WAGE WORKER CLIENTS --
MANY OF WHOM JUST AREN'T AWARE
OF THEIR RIGHTS BY THE TIME THEY
FIND OUT WHAT THEIR RATES ARE
THEY'VE USUALLY MISTER A ONE
YEAR STATUTE AND HAVE NO
RECOURSE --
AT ALL FOR WHAT THEY'VE SUFFERED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL OF FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT I WOULD
JUST ADD I WAS WATCHING NEWS
COVERAGE OF THE COLON HEARINGS.
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR LYING
ON FORMS THAT YOU SUBMIT TO A
BANK BEING TEN YEARS AND I
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS BILL AND I
THOUGHT ABOUT ALL THE WORKERS.
WHO HAVE NO RECOURSE AFTER ONE
YEAR WHERE IS BANKS ARE
PROTECTED FOR TEN WE HAVE TO
CHANGE THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
RENEE BY RSU CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PAM LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF WORK
EQUITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MANDY BENSON ON BEHALF OF WORK
EQUITY AND ALSO I'M A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINER
INVESTIGATOR --
I DO A LOT OF WORK IN THIS AREA
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MAP BROWN BE AFTER
THE TEAMSTERS EIGHTY YOU MACHINE
S. -- I HAVE
P. T. LOCAL TWENTY AND TWENTY
ONE I YOU KNOW HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THE I ANGER MAY CELIA
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I LEASE IT OUT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
A DENTIST SEEKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CHURCH TAKE COUNSEL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON LAURA CURTIS --
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN AND OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY.
WE ARE HERE AN IMPOSING LESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE EXTENDING THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS REDUCES OBVIOUSLY
THEY EMPLOYEES OR MOTIVATION TO
COME FOR IS THE EMPLOYER'S
ABILITY TO RADICALLY THE PROBLEM
THESE AT THESE OCCURRENCES ARE
LIMITED TO WORKPLACE HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND RETALIATION.
SO IF THE EMPLOYER IS NOT MADE
AWARE OF WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
IN THE WORKPLACE THEN THEY CAN
ACTUALLY ACT TO CORRECT IT.
EMPLOYERS DON'T WANT HARASSMENT
LEAST OUR MEMBERS DON'T WANT
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION
RETALIATION OCCURRING IN THE
WORKPLACE NOT ONLY FOR THE
EMPLOYEE MORALE PURPOSE BUT FOR
THE LIABILITY PURPOSES WELL.
AND LAST YEAR THIS BILL --
WHICH WAS AN IDENTICAL VERSION
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY MINUTES THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND HE VETOED
THE BILL SAYING EMPLOYEES WHO
EXPERIENCE TRESTMAN OR
DISCRIMINATION THE WORKPLACE
SHOULD HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THEIR COMPLAINTS
INVESTIGATED.
I BELIEVE HOWEVER THAT THE
CURRENT FILING DEADLINE WHICH IS
BEEN IN PLACE SINCE NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE NOT ONLY ENCOURAGES
PROP REPLICA RESOLUTION WILL
MEMORIES IN EVIDENCE ARE FRESH
BUT ALSO ENSURES THAT THE
UNWELCOME BEHAVIOR IS PROMPTLY
REPORTED.
AND SO THAT'S OUR CONCERN IS
THAT THIS COULD CONTINUE TO GO
ON AN OF PLACES THE CONCERNS OF
THE VICTIM ON TOP OF POTENTIAL
FUTURE VICTIMS WHO MIGHT BE ALSO
HARASSED IF NO ONE'S MADE AWARE
OF WHAT'S OCCURRING --
AND ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSED
SUCH A LIMITATION TO SIX TIMES
LONGER THAN THE FEDERAL E. O. C.
STANDARD THAT'S ONLY A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS THE CURRENT STATURE
LIMITATIONS IS DOUBLE THE
STATE'S STANDARD --
OR THE CURRENT SPECIAL
IMITATIONS IS DOUBLE THE FEDERAL
STANDARD THIS WOULD EXTEND TO
SIX TIMES THE FEDERAL STANDARD
AND THREE TIMES A STATE STANDARD
ALSO THE VICTIM DOES HAVE OTHER
AVENUES OF RELIEF NOT ONLY
CRIMINAL CHARGES DEPENDING ON
THE SEVERITY OF THE MATTER.
BUT YOU CAN ALSO FILE A CLAIM
CIVILLY FOR INTENTIONAL
INFLICTION OF EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
ASSAULT BATTERY AND THOSE DO
HAVE A TWO YEAR SESSION WHEN THE
PATIENTS --
FOR UNDER THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING ACT EMPLOYERS HAVE A
DUTY TO NOTIFY ALL EMPLOYEES OF
THE ONE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS SO THERE IS THAT
DUTY AS WELL TO TO NOTIFY THEM
OF THAT AND SO FOR THESE REASONS
WERE ASKING. FOR THE BILL TO BE
LIMITED TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ONLY SINCE THAT'S IMPETUS FOR
THE BILL AND WE'RE ALSO --
ASKING THAT THE RETROACTIVITY
LÏNG.
IF I COULD JUST TO REQUEST
BECAUSE IT IS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION MISTER CHAIR IN
THE IN THE BILL IN SECTION ONE
IN SUBDIVISION DE --
IF YOU COULD LIMITED --
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT THERE
INSTEAD OF AS BROAD AS THE
CURRENT LANGUAGES.
BY THE WAY IT SAYS ARTICLES IT
SHOULD SAY ARTICLE.
AND THEN IN SECTION TWO WE HAD
HAD DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS ISSUE
EXTENSIVELY IN THE OTHER HOUSE
IS POLICY COMMITTEE.
THE LANGUAGE UTILIZES IT
SHOULDN'T BE INTERPRETED TO
REVISE.
REVIVAL LAPS CLAIMS WE WOULD
RATHER HAVE A VERY.
EXPLICIT PROSPECT OF STATEMENT
THAT THE BILL SHOULD BE AFFECT
FOR CLAIMS.
FILED ON OR AFTER JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY NINETEEN AND LASTLY I
THINK WE HAVE SOME GENERAL
CONCERN ABOUT WHAT.
THE ABILITY OF D. F. E. H.. TO
HANDLE EVERYTHING THAT'S LIKELY
TO COME --
WITH THIS BILL IF ENACTED.
BY THE MOST RECENT DATA WE HAVE
SEEN TWENTY THOUSAND COMPLAINTS.
OVER FORTY ONE HUNDRED OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN DISMISSED DUE TO LACK
OF EVIDENCE.
THOSE NUMBERS ON BOTH SIDES ARE
GOING TO GO UP CONSIDERABLY WITH
THIS LEGISLATION SO.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THE THE POINTS
THAT THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
HAVE RAISED WITH IT --
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT A
MORE LIMITED IN ITS APPLICATION
THANK THINKING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FEEDBACK OF ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY FOR
ACCESSIBLE JUSTICE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION FOR THE REASONS STATED.
THANK YOU.
HI THIS PAID BACK. TO THE
COMMITTEE --
AND WE ALREADY DO HAVE A MOTION --
THE TO MOVE THE BILL FROM AS A
MEMBER BECAUSE ALL SECOND BY
SUMMER CARILLO ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SOME RESULTS I JUST I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING BACK THIS
BILL AND I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKING ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO
YOU WE KNOW AND I MEAN IT'S
ALMOST IN THE NEWS DAILY --
THAT SURVIVOR THE USE --
DEAL WITH IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND
AND IT TAKES TIME AND I THINK
THAT'S BECOMING MORE MORE CLEAR
IN OUR SOCIETY SAID HEAR PEOPLE
SAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE FEDERAL
STANDARD IS A HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS WILL SOMETHING'S WRONG WITH
FEDERAL STANDARD --
BECAUSE IT IS --
THE EXPECTATION THAT A WOMAN OR
MAN WHO FACES THIS WOULD --
REACT EQUALLY AT WITHIN A SHORT
TIME PERIOD ESPECIALLY FACING --
JOB LOSS IN BEING A SINGLE
MOTHER IN THIS COMPLIMENTS FOR
SOME OTHER BILLS WERE DOING AS
WELL BUT THANK YOU FOR COMING
AND SPEAKING THE TRUTH TO THAT --
I I JUST COMMEND YOU IT'S HARD
TO DEAL AND AND WE HEARD YOU
LOUD AND CLEAR SO I'M PROUD OF
FOR THIS BILL TODAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THE SERVER DID.
IS THIS CHAIRMAN I I ALSO I TOO
WOULD LIKE --
TO ECHO --
MISTER DOLLARS IS COMMON --
A NO I THAT I THINK WAS REYES
FOR BRING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
I THINK HER WITNESS.
FOR US SO FOR FOR HER COURAGE IN
COMING --
BEFORE AS PUBLICLY --
TO SHARE HER STORY AND AND AND
AND I SEE THAT --
THE THE THE REASON --
BEHIND THIS LEGISLATION IS --
TO MAKE SURE THAT --
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
SEXUAL.
VIOLENCE OR OR GIVEN THEIR THEIR
THEIR TIME AND AND THEY'RE
MIDDLE ENOUGH TIME.
TO GO THROUGH WITH THEIR
EMOTIONAL PROCESS IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT --
THE SEEK WHATEVER JUST AS THE
THE SEEM FIT --
I WOULD ASK MISS RAY AS IF SHE
WOULD CONSIDER.
NARROWING THE SCOPE OF OF HER
BILL. TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT --
CLAIMS --
MEANING --
I'M OF EXTENDING THE THE STATUE
OF LIMITATION FROM ONE YEAR TO
TWO YEARS --
BUT WHAT WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO
LIMIT THAT SCHOOL TO JUST SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND AND ANYTHING HAS
TO DO WITH.
OF THAT NATURE.
I DO WANT --
TO SAY SOMETHING --
THAT WAS ALREADY MENTIONED
EARLIER THIS BILL MADE IT
THROUGH COMMITTEE THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY THROUGH THE SENATE.
AND GOT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK.
AND THIS WAS THE FORM.
SO WE HAD TO WE'VE TAKEN A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS PREVIOUSLY
AND THIS WAS THE FINAL BILL THAT.
WE AS A BODY BOTH PARTIES HAD
AGREED -- TO
I THINK THAT THAT THE THE
LANGUAGE IT'S I WILL CERTAINLY
TALK TO TO TO THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT THEIR POSITION --
BUT WE HAD.
LOTS OF DISCUSSIONS OF LAST YEAR
AND ARRIVED AT THE LANGUAGE THAT
WAS.
THE BEST FIT THAT WOULD PROVIDE
TO THE PROTECTIONS THAT WERE
NEEDED --
FOR THE VICTIMS AND THUS WE CAME
UP WITH THE LANGUAGE AS WE HAVE
IT.
IF I CAN ADDRESS THAT --
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AT
COVERS --
CLAIMS OF US GENDER
DISCRIMINATION OSMAN ALL TYPES
OF UNPROTECTED CATEGORY SO IT
WOULD BE A DIFFICULT LIMITATION
TO ONLY LIMIT THE BILL TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BECAUSE A LOT OF
CLAIMS THAT COME FORWARD.
HAVE INTEREST SEXUALITY WITH
OTHER TYPES OF CLAIMS LIKE AGE
DISCRIMINATION OR GENDER
DISCRIMINATION OR SOME KIND OF
OTHER PROTECTION UNDER UNDER
FIFA SO TO BE A VERY DIFFICULT
THING.
TO HAVE ONE CLAIM IN IN A IN IN
ONE LAWSUIT BE THREE YEARS AND
AND KEEP THE OTHERS IT'S A MUCH
SHORTER TIME SO --
THE BILL PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE
CLAIMS UNDER THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING --
TO THE THREE YEARS --
AND NOT AND NOT IT'S JUST NOT
WORKABLE TO DO IT WITH JUST --
ONE ASPECT OF THE PROTECTIONS
AND ALSO WANTED TO ADDRESS --
UP THE OPPOSITION'S COMMENT
ABOUT THE BILL.
I PREVENTING VICTIMS FROM COMING
FORWARD QUICKLY ENOUGH.
AS YOU HEARD FROM MS SANDERS SHE
WENT THE VERY NEXT MONDAY TO
REPORT WHAT HAPPENED TO HER I'M
IGNORES THE FACT THAT WITH MEN
AND AND VICTIMS OF
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT.
DO NOT COME FORWARD BECAUSE OF
THE ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE TO
DEAL WITH MENTALLY ALSO THE FEAR
AND THE HUMILIATION AND ALL THE
OTHER FACTORS THAT PREVENT THEM
FROM COMING FORWARD IT IS NOT A
BILL THAT'S GOING TO DISCOURAGE.
PEOPLE FROM COMING FORWARD THERE
ARE REALITIES AS TO WHY THAT'S
THE CASE AND SO THE FIX IS TO
EXTEND THE STATUTE --
AS FAR AS OTHER REMEDIES THAT
ARE THERE LIKE INTENTIONAL
INFLICTION OF EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
THOSE ARE COMMON LAW CLAIMS THAT
TO NOT HAVE THE SAME REMEDY THE
PROTECTIONS THAT THE HOUSE.
SUCH AS YOU KNOW THE COMMON LAW
CLAIMS TO NOT HAVE SO THAT IS
WHY IT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED
WITHIN THE STATUTE.
THANK YOU I ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
I'M I I WANNA --
THANK MY COLLEAGUES WERE OF THE
RECOGNITION APPROPRIATE USE OF
THE COURAGE. TO COME FORWARD AND
SPEAK OF SOMETHING SO PERSONAL
AND I THINK IT DEMONSTRATES THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL --
I'M VERY GRATEFUL SUMMARY IS
THAT YOU BRING IT BACK AGAIN I'M
I'M I'M ARE ALREADY A HAPPY
COOPER ON IT BECAUSE I THINK I
THINK AS YOU CORRECTLY INDICATED.
THROUGH A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND I KNOW HOW HARD YOU WORKED.
TO GET IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK --
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS A
MEANINGFUL BILL --
THAT TOOK INTO ACCOUNT ALL THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED DURING
THE COURSE OF LAST SESSION.
I DON'T AGREE WITH GOVERNOR
BROWN AT MS A LOT OF REASONS WHY
VICTIMS DON'T COME FORWARD RIGHT
AWAY.
AND AND YOU KNOW HE CAN'T BE
RIGHT ON EVERYTHING HE WAS RIGHT
ON THIS.
ONE AND AS A REALITY AND SO --
I'M TECHNICIANS AND I AND WE DO
HAVE A MOTION --
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
GONZALESSECOND BIKE SUMMER
CARILLO AND ALLOW AS MARIA'S YOU
HAVE ANY FINAL CLOSING COMMENTS.
I WOULDN'T --
JUST REITERATE WHAT TO ON MY
COLLEAGUE --
HAS.
ALREADY SHARED WITH YOU --
WHEN YOU'RE SIMPLY IS NOT ENOUGH
AND IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT D.
F. E. H. IN THE LAWS UNDER THE
F. T. H. THEN WE HAVE TO STAY
WITHIN THOSE LAWS?
AND EXTENDING THE THAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER IT'S A
PERSONAL INJURY HAVE TWO YEARS
IF IT'S FRAUD THREE YEARS
CONTRACT DISPUTE FOR YEARS.
AND THE BANK FRAUD OF UP TO TEN
YEARS.
GIVING A VICTIM THREE YEARS
SHOULD BE THE MINIMUM BUT WE
PROVIDE TO THEM AND THAT IS WHAT
I'M ASKING SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SOME AREAS OF THEM SO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE TABLE
CALL THE VOTE.
DO YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CREO.
CARILLO EYES DEEP [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
NOT VOTING.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I BONTA
REVERSE.
REVERSE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
I HAD A HEAD OVER TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SERVICE [inaudible]
AS SPEAKING APPROPRIATIONS A
SUMMER GONZALEZ AND YOU HAVE A
COUPLE MORE ABILITY LIKE A
PRESENT.
BUT HERE'S MY QUESTION THAT IS
JUST CLOSE UP DISCOUNT.
SELECTION HAS TRANSPORT FOODS --
DECEMBER GONZALEZ AB ONE SEVENTY
AND THEN AB ONE SEVENTY ONE IS
THAT OKAY YES AB RIGHTLY.
AND AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE FOR
THESE TWO ITEMS FOR BEING
PATIENT.
WE'LL START WITH AB --
ONE SEVENTY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AS THIS BILL YOU
ALSO SAW LAST YEAR WE ACTUALLY
HAD THE NEXT TWO BILLS IN ONE
BILL WE'VE NOW --
AS CREATED TWO BILLS OUT OF IT
SO --
PEOPLE'S CONFUSION CAN BE
LESSENED.
HOPEFULLY SINCE THAT WAS THE
REASON APPARENTLY IT WAS OF
THOSE MOVIES HAVE A TOAD.
THANK YOU --
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT WENT A LONG
WAY TO PROTECT US INTO FURTHER
DIALOGUE ON HOW TO BETTER
PROTECT WORKERS HOWEVER THE
EXPERIENCE OF WORKERS IN
HOSPITALITY AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES.
ARE OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION AB ONE SEVENTY AS
PART OF A PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT
SEEKS TO PROTECT OUR VULNERABLE
LOW WAGE WORKERS WERE OFTEN
IMMIGRANTS IN OFTEN WOMEN.
WHO ARE IN NEED OF THE MOST
PERFECT WE'VE SEEN ESPECIALLY A
JANITORIAL AND HOTEL
HOUSEKEEPING SERVICES HAS BEEN
TOWARD OUTSOURCING WORK TO
STAFFING AGENCIES?
THESE WORKERS MAY GO TO WORK
EACH DAY AT THE SAME LOCATION
WHEN THE UNIFORM OF THE OFFICE
OUR HOTEL THEIR CLEANING AND
REPORTING TO MANAGERS ON SITE.
WORKERS ARE IN MANY CASES NOT
AWARE OF THEIR JUST SUB
CONTRACTING AGENCY OR THEIR
DIRECT SUPERVISOR.
IN SPITE OF THIS CLEAR TO FACTOR
WORKPLACE.
AND MANAGERS THESE CONTRACTING
COMPANIES AND HOTELS ARE NOT
HELD RESPONSIBLE ONE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ASSAULT HAPPENS ON
THEIR WATCH TO THEIR WORKERS
WHAT HAS RESULTED FROM THIS LACK
OF ACCOUNTABILITY ARE HORROR
STORIES OF ABUSE IS THE
WORKPLACE IS.
PERPETRATED BY THE SAME ACTORS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AB ONE
SEVENTY WOULD ENSURE THE
CONTRACTED WORKERS CAN SEEK
RECOURSE FROM BOTH THEIR DIRECT
EMPLOYER.
AND THEIR CONTRACTING CLIENT
EMPLOYER IF THEY EXPERIENCE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ASSAULT
DISCRIMINATION RETALIATION IN
THE WORKPLACE.
BY REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO SHARE
CIVIL LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY IN
CIVIL LIABILITY WORKERS WILL BE
MORE POWER TO HAVE THE REPORTS
TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND HOLD THEIR
ACCOUNTABLE THEIR WORKERS PLACE.
THIS BILL WAS INSPIRED BY THE
STORY OF TIME PERSON YEARS
SANDERS GATHER SCAPA WHO BRAVELY
CAME FOR TO TELL HER STORY THE
WORLD UNFORTUNATELY --
AS A WORKING SINGLE MOTHER
SANDRA WAS AN ABLE TO JOIN US
TODAY BUT A FORMER CO WORKER
SANDERS WHO FACED A SHOCKINGLY
SIMILAR EXPERIENCE OF THE VERY
SAME RESORT WILL SHARE HER
TESTIMONY TODAY.
MONICA.
WELL LET'S LOOK --
LESLIE MONICA SONGES --
YES THEY ARE KEEPING A COMPARTIR
MYSTERY OF THAT GOT CANCELED
LOCAL ESPERANZA THE THEIR SON
TOOK ON THE FINANCE OF THE GET
OUT OF IT SAID THAT THE BEEN
THAT ONE THING.
COMMON SET UP A HOT AND AN ADULT
MALE CAT THORNTON THAT ARE NEVER
SOLD BELOW UP LET THOSE.
OTHER OTHER THE NET.
TO THE PERSONAL NOT OF YOUR
MOTHER SEN. FOR YOUR CASA.
BOTTOM FOR BUT WE SAW --
GOOD SUPPORT WHAT IS.
BODY ELSE MISSES THIS WAS THE
MAN PLAY ALL.
THIS AND YOU ALSO THE A COMMON
SAW SETTLEMENT ALLOWANCES SIX
WIRELESS A SEMI.
ME THE SEVEN THAT THE WHOLE.
MANY HOGAN I JUANITA EAGLES THAT
IS ILLEGAL MEANWHILE FOR THE
ABOUT HOW LATE HE CANNOT STOMACH
THE THOUGHT THAT.
UNDER THE LOTUS AT THE AMPLE.
COMMENTS UPROAR WILL NOT GET
THAT.
ONE A CONFLICT LOCAL MINISTRY AT
THAT WITH THEM.
I'M SICK OF PICKING.
ON THE ADMISSIBILITY SO MANY
HOLE IS A VEHICLE ELLISON WITH
YOUR OWN SECRET IN MY HORRIBLE
NORTH IS THE ABOUT THE ABOUT THE
LHASA DISPOSAL INTENT THIS.
FEEL LIKE GOING TO FIT INTO THAT
RIGHT NOW.
JIMMY MARCUS ELOQUENT THEY CAN
LOOK AT THE HOTEL MESA'S
INCLUDING COMMA.
JAMIE SAID TO YOUR OTHER ME THE
MEGA [inaudible]
GAIL ZAPPA.
JIMMY NOISE ANOTHER AND A FLUTE
DIFFERENT THEM YOU'LL.
YOU'LL SEE THEM INTO IN ANOTHER
ANOTHER SONG INCLUDE THAT YOU
MEAN.
THIS BILL GOES TO PREVENT THE
BREAKUP OF THE LATE BUT AGAIN
WITH THE HOST OF THE KING TOOK
ONLY A THING OF BOTH YEAH I'M
GOOD WITH THE BIRTH OF CALM.
THE DINOSAURS SAID WITH ONE
THOUGHT.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
I'M GONNA NAMES MY MIDDLE AND
TRANSLATE THAT HER TESTIMONY SO.
OF MINIMUS MONEY GOT SHOT
SANCHEZ AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
SHARE MY STORY OF A STALL IN
HOPES THAT.
AB ONE SEVENTY MOVES FORWARD.
I BEGAN WORKING IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AT THE TEN TURNOUT
RESORT AS A DISHWASHER THROUGH
STOPPING AGENCY CALLED EXCEL.
I WAS HARASSED BY A SUPERVISOR
WHO ALLEGEDLY HARASSING
ASSAULTED ANOTHER ONE OF MY
COWORKERS UNENDING FAIL STUDY
THAT.
SEVERAL MONTHS INTO MY
EMPLOYMENT MISSISSIPPI BUT BEGAN
TO MAKE SEXUAL ADVANCES TOWARD
ME WHILE AT WORK.
HE TOLD ME THAT I WAS PRETTY AND
THAT HE WOULD HE WOULD LIKE TO
GO OUT WITH ME OUTSIDE OF WORK.
I TOLD THEM I WAS NOT INTERESTED.
AT ABOUT THAT TIME HE BEGAN TO
SCHEDULED TO SHIP THE CONFLICTED
WITH MY NEED TO WATCH MY YOUNG
CHILDREN. ONE DAY MY SUPERVISOR
TOLD ME THAT.
I KNEW WAS I KNEW WHAT THE
SOLUTION WAS.
IF I WANTED BETTER SHIPS.
I WAS TERRIFIED.
AFTER THE INCIDENT I WANT TO
SPEAK WITH TURNING A MANAGER
JIMY MARQUEZ AND TOLD HIM WHAT
DALE SAID IT MADE ME FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE.
JIMMY LAUGHED AT MY COMPLETE.
AS FAR AS I KNOW JIMMY DID NOT
DO ANYTHING AT ALL ABOUT THE
ISSUE.
MY EXPERIENCE IS WORKING AT THE
TURNING OVER TRAUMATIC FOR ME.
WHEN I WAS WORKING THERE AND
THEY'LL WAS HARASSING ME HE I
FELT SCARED AND DEPRESSED I FELT
LIKE I WAS LOAN? EIGHT MORE
WOMEN HAVE COME FORWARD STORY TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT AT
THE CHAIR NEAR RESORT MYSELF
INCLUDED.
I HOPE THIS BILL PASSES TO GIVE
AGENCY WORKERS LIKE MYSELF THE
VOICE AND HOLD COMPANIES THAT
THE TORNADO RESTORE RESPONSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS SANCHEZ FOR YOUR
COURAGE.
TO SPEAK FOR US TODAY.
STATE MR TURN MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION KAREN STRONG SUPPORT
AN HONOR TO BE HERE WITH US THE
ONE AS BRAVE AS MONICA WHO CAME.
GIVE ME TO SHARE HER STORY AND
WE OFTEN SEE WHEN COMPANIES USE
THIRD PARTIES TO PROVIDE WORKERS
THAT THEY TRY TO ASSERT THAT
SOMEHOW THEY HAVE NO OBLIGATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WORKERS
GET PAID. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WORKERS ARE SAFE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WORKERS ARE
TREATED WITH RESPECT --
FOR THAT REASON WE DID A BILL
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THAT SAID WHEN
A COMPANY USES A THIRD PARTY TO
BRING WORKERS TO DO THE REGULAR
WORK IN THE BUSINESS.
THEY SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE IF
THOSE WORKERS DON'T GET PAID IF
THERE ISN'T A SAFE WORKPLACE IF
THEY DON'T HAVE WORKERS COMP
PROVIDED AND THAT IS THE LAW
TODAY.
IT DOESN'T APPLY TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THAT'S WHY THIS BILL
IS SO IMPORTANT THAT MEANS THAT
THE COMPANY THE HOTEL THAT WAS
USING THE STAFFING AGENCY HAS NO
FINANCIAL REASON TO INTERVENE.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
WOMEN ARE PROTECT.
SO THIS THIS WOULD SAY THESE ARE
THE WOMEN DOING THE WORK OF YOUR
HOTEL YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO TURN
AWAY AND ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE
TO BE ABUSED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE TO CONSUMERS.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVENTY AND ONE SEVENTY ONE
REYES HERE YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
MANDY BENSON ON BEHALF OF WORK
EQUITY AND AND EVENTS AND
CONSULTING AND SUPPORT.
WHEN DID YOU SELL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT?
PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF WORK
EQUITY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVENTY AND ONE SEVENTY ONE DOES
THE CENTER ABOUT LEGAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF THE
TEAMSTERS UNITE HERE AT YOU --
MACHINISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
.
HI LAURA CURTIS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY WE
ARE HERE AND THEN THE POST
POSITION ON AB.
ONE SEVENTY THE REASON IS IS
THAT THIS STATUTORY MANDATE ARE --
IGNORES AND DISRUPTS LAWS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY ALREADY IN PLACE
FOR THESE PURPOSES SO IF A IF
HARASSMENT OCCURS OF THE PERSON
PROVIDING SERVICES PURSUANT TO A
CONTRACT.
UNDER THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING ACT AS TO AND IT'S DONE
BY A SUPERVISORY EMPLOYEE THEN
THE CLIENT EMPLOYERS RT STRICTLY
LIABLE IF A NON SUPERVISORY
EMPLOYEE HARASSES SOMEONE.
THAT IS PROVIDING SERVICES TO AT
PURSUANT TO A CONTRACT THAN THE
STANDARD IS KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN.
IF THE CLIENT EMPLOYER WILL ALSO
BE HELD PARTY TO THAT CLIENT
EMPLOYERS OWN EMPLOYEES.
THAN THAT --
KLEIN EMPLOYER WILL BE HELD
LIABLE THE THE EMPLOYER ALWAYS
HAS THE DUTY TO PROTECT THEIR
OWN EMPLOYEES THEY ALSO HAVE A
DUTY AGAIN TO PROVIDE TO PROTECT
PERSONS PROVIDING SERVICES.
PURSUANT TO CONTRACT DEPENDING
ON THE STANDARD IT'S KNEW OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN OR IT'S AN S.
SIGNIFICAN OUT OF CONTROL OVER
THIS INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE IF THE
INDIVIDUAL DOESN'T EVEN PER
DOESN'T EVEN MEET THE STANDARD
FOR OR THAT --
DEFINITION FOR PERSONS PROVIDING
SERVICES PURSUANT TO A CONTRACT
BUT THE CLIENT EMPLOYER IS SEEM
TO HAVE --
HAD ENOUGH CONTROL OVER THIS
INDIVIDUAL TO ACT LIKE THE REAL
PLAYER THEY'RE STILL LIABILITY
HOWEVER AB SEVEN ONE SEVENTY
IMPOSES JOINT LIABILITY EVEN IF
THE EMPLOYEES OF THAT CLIENT
EMPLOYER ARE NOT INVOLVED AT ALL.
SO IF TO JANITORS THAT ARE IN
YOU KNOW A FACILITY THAT HARASS
EACH OTHER THAN NOT ONLY IS THE
IN THE LABOR CONTRACTOR LIABLE
BUT NOW THE CLIENT EMPLOYERS
LIABLE EVEN THOUGH THEY HAD NO
CONTROL.
THEY HAD NO KNOWLEDGE THEY HAD
KNOWN SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
KNOWLEDGE AHA ON THE ISSUE
THEY'RE STILL GOING TO BE HELD
LIABLE AND LAST YEAR A SIMILAR
BILL OR PROVISION OF AB THIRTY
EIGHTY ONE THAT WAS VETOED AND
IN THE VETO MESSAGE.
GOVERNOR BROWN SAID THIS BILL
CREATES NEW ILL DEFINED
STANDARDS OF JOINT LIABILITY
BETWEEN LABOR CONTRACTORS
INCLINE EMPLOYERS PERMITS BOTH
ENTITIES FOR MENTALITY AGAINST
EMPLOYEE WHOSE FATHER HARASSMENT
CLAIM AND ESTABLISHES A THIRTY
DAY NOTICE REQUIREMENT BEFORE
CERTAIN WORKERS CAN FILE CIVIL
ACTION AGAINST EMPLOYER.
MOST OF THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL ARE CONTAINED IN CURRENT
LAW AND ARE THERE UNNECESSARY TO
CONSISTENT THAT THEIR NEW
PROVISIONS THEY ARE CONFUSING.
SO THE CURRENT STANDARD IS WHAT
WE THINK SHOULD STILL BE IN
PLACE --
BECAUSE AT LEAST THAT HAS THE
STANDARD OF EITHER CONTROLLED
KNEW HER SHOULD HAVE KNOWN OR
PROVIDES A STRICT LIABILITY IF
IT'S A AND A SUPERVISOR EMPLOYEE
OF THE CLIENT EMPLOYER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER CHRIS SPECULATE AGAIN
I DON'T WANT --
TO IN ANY WAY BE VIEWED AS
CONDONING THE ACTIVITY THAT THE
AUTHORS WITNESSES TESTIFIED TO I
THINK THIS IS A EXAMPLE OF
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE RIGHT
APPROACH THE LANGUAGE CONTAINED
IN.
AB ONE THE SEVENTY IS
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME LANGUAGE
LABOR CODE SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
TEN POINT THREE WHICH WAS.
THE LABOR FEDERATION'S --
ROGER HERNANDEZ SPONSORED BILL --
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN IF I
RECALL THE NUMBER CORRECTLY.
THAT WAS FOR THE PAYMENT OF
WAGES AND VALID WORKERS COMP
COVERAGE FOR THE EMPLOYEES OF
THE CONTRACTOR.
ITEMS WHICH ARE I GUESS IN MY
MIND OBJECTIVELY VERIFIABLE.
AS OPPOSED TO THE LANGUAGE HERE
THAT HAS BEEN PLACED INTO THE
FIAT STATUTE IN THE GOVERNMENT
CODE. FOR HARASSMENT WHICH IS
NOT AN OBJECTIVELY VERIFIABLE --
APPROACH.
THAT WERE STANDARD THAT COULD BE
UTILIZED ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
EMPLOYEES OF THE CONTRACTOR.
AND THE OTHER DIFFICULT ASPECT
IS IS THAT THE NOTICE IN
TRAINING MANDATES CONTAINED IN
THE FEE HIGH STATUTE FOR EXAMPLE.
DON'T PROVID IF YOU WILL ANY
SORT OF GOOD FAITH DEFENSE ON
THE PART OF THE EMPLOYING ENTITY.
I DON'T KNOW PERHAPS OR SOME
SORT OF AN APPROACH WITH THE YOU
KNOW WHY A BAD THAT THE STATE OF
PUTS TOGETHER BUT THERE'S GOT TO
BE SOME SORT OF AN ABILITY.
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE VERY
VALID POINTS THAT MISS CURTIS
HAS RAISED WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME.
ENSURING THAT THE EXAMPLE THAT
THE WITNESS DESCRIBED DOES NOT
GO UNPUNISHED.
SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MATTHEW WELL OF WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE WOULD
ALIGN OUR OUR POSITION AND WITH
AND WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY --
MISS CURTIS CAM MISTER MCKINLEY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING
HEY JACK ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
PISTACHIO GROWERS CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS AND GROWTH ASSOCIATION
AND WESTERN PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION.
IN OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BROWN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION LIKE TO ALIGN US WITH
THE OF FOR OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED BY THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THANK YOU.
THE KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED AS
WELL.
THANK YOU.
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY FOR THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THAT'S SOME RIGOROUS.
SENATE AVENCHES LIGULA LET US AS
PART OF ANY.
ORDER THAT THIS EAGLE THAT THE
LOOK AT MAYBE THEY'LL THIS WSU
FREMANTLE.
NOISE SELLABLE MONOCLE MORE
[inaudible]
THE THAT THE ALMA.
IT THEM INCENTIVE SICK I CAN
PICK IT UP OR YEAH.
NEEDLESS TO THE NEXT I WOULD QUE
LES SIMPLY SOMEONE SALAS.
MOTORS AND ALSO THOSE THAT ARE
HOMELESS AGAIN AND CAPITAL IS
ALMOST AS A LEVEL.
APPLE YONDER Là UMASS ILLNESS A
STUDY ABOUT A BULLET --
SUBACUTE CAN GO ANOTHER ORDER
YOU LIST ALL THE CALIFORNIA
APPLE YET TOTAL THROW A LOTUS
KILLED US IN CLINTON AND LET
CAKE HE SAYS THE STATE.
NOTHING IN THE POLITICAL
CONSISTING THAT WILL STEP IN TO
GET THINGS.
BUT SELECT THE ENABLED US TO
SPECULATE WITH GLASSES.
THANK YOU.
HAVE A QUESTION.
FOR I THANK YOU FOR YOUR YEARS
COMING INTO THE CAPITOL TODAY
AND BRING THIS FORWARD I THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW AS A FATHER OF TWO
LITTLE GIRLS --
I KNOW WHAT I WOULD DO IF I
FOUND OUT THE SOMEBODY'S DOING
THIS MY KIDS YEAH THIS IS
INCREDIBLY I'M SERIOUS TO ALL OF
US.
THERE IS ONE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
AND AS A AND MISS FOSTER THIS IS
KIND OF SOMETHING THAT.
YOU KNOW IS MORE DIRECTED AT YOU
BECAUSE I IT'S THIS IS NOT AN
EASY BILL TO TONOT BE
SUPPORTIVE OF BECAUSE IT IS SO
INCREDIBLY SERIOUS.
BUT ON THAT SMALL BUSINESS SIDE
IF IF WE AS AN EMPLOYER WE ARE
CONTRACTING SOMEBODY AND YOU
KNOW TO HELP US OUT FOR HOWEVER
LONG THAT MAY BE.
AND WE HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF
THEIR BUSINESS PRACTICES PRIOR
AND AND I AND THERE MAY BE.
NO AS I THINK IT'S ANGIE'S LIST
YOU MAYBE THERE'S SOME
OPPORTUNITY OUT THERE WHERE YOU
CAN GET --
BACKGROUND ON EMPLOYEE YOU KNOW.
BUSINESSES YOU KNOW AS YOU HIRE
THEM IN BUT IF WE HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT AND YOU HIRE
SOMEBODY IN ON THE GOOD FAITH.
AND THEN THEY DO SOMETHING
HORRIBLE LIKE THIS IT'S JUST
HARD FOR ME TO PIN THAT ON THE
EMPLOYER.
ON THAT HIRING AGENCY AND SO I
DO APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING ABLE
TO SUPPORT THIS BUT IT'S REALLY
VERY SIMPLE THING FOR ME I THINK.
YOU KNOW IF IF THIS BILL TAKES
AMENDMENTS AND IT DOES BECOME SO
EXPANSIVE IT IS VERY SUPPORT.
BUT WE CAN'T HOLD PEOPLE IN MY
OPINION SMALL BUSINESSES LIABLE
FOR ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE ZERO
CONTROL OVER SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR AND AND I
WOULD SAY LOOK.
WHO'S IN THE BEST POSITION. TO
BE ABLE. TO MAKE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT.
IS IT THE WORKER THAT'S BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF OR THE
EMPLOYER EVEN IF THE CONTRACT
WAS SOMEONE ELSE TO COME ONTO
THEIR PROPERTY.
WHO'S IN THE BETTER POSITION AND
I'VE AND THAT'S WHY I'M.
BECAUSE I THINK CLEARLY AND
THERE THE BY AND LARGE OF I
DON'T THINK I'LL BE AT ALL I
HOPE AGREE THAT.
AN EMPLOYER IS IN A BETTER
POSITION TO CREATE THAT SAME
ENVIRONMENT AND IF THEY'RE
BRINGING.
OF FOLKS ONTO THEIR PROPERTY AS
OPPOSED.
TO HAVING THE VICTIMS BE THE
ONES THAT HAVE TO IN A NOT JUST
WE DEAL WITH THE THE THE
SUFFERING.
OF BEING VICTIMIZED AND I'LL THE
THE HORRIBLE THINGS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT ON TOP OF THAT TO
PUT THE BURDEN ON THEM.
THAT AND GO TO THE PROCESS OF
RAISING ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN THE EMPLOYER
THAT'S CONTRACTING --
Và DOESN'T HAVE THE THE THE
SAME KIND OF LIABILITY I THINK
THAT THAT.
PRESSURE FROM THE LIABILITY WELL
CLASS ACTION AND CAUSE MUCH MORE
OVER KEEN OVERSIGHT AND THERE
SHOULD BE OVERSIGHT IF YOU'RE
NOT A CONTRACT OUT.
CERTAIN SERVICES A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON YOUR PROPERTY --
YOU BETTER KNOW WHO WHO'S ON
YOUR PROPERTY THAT EVERYONE ON
YOUR PROPERTY SAFE AT ALL TIMES
AND SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT WHY
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK THAT.
THE ONUS SHOULD BE ON THE THOSE
THAT ARE IN POWER TO MAKE THE
CHANGES AND MAKE THE COULD MAKE
THE ENVIRONMENT SAFE.
AND NOT ON THOSE THAT ARE BEING
VICTIMIZED AT THE LEE
ENVIRONMENTS.
AND SO FOR THAT FOR THAT REASON
THAT RECOGNITION WHICH HAS NINE
FEET IN OUR TO GUESS IT.
AND IF ANY IF THERE'S NOTHING
ELSE WILL TURN BACK DECEMBER
GONZALEZ.
SO -- I
APPRECIATE THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT TO BE QUITE
HONEST I HAVEN'T HEARD THIS IN A
SMALL BUSINESS CAPACITY BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WORKERS WERE
ON YOUR PROPERTY UNDER YOUR
CONTROL --
SO IT'S AYE AYE.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHY THAT OFF
Q. IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
WHAT HOW THIS ACTUALLY HAPPENS
IN THE WORKPLACE --
I I THINK THAT MAYBE THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ON ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE BECAUSE WE
TALK ABOUT.
LARGELY STAFFING AGENCIES YOU
KNOW WHO COME AND AND AND THOSE
WORKERS ARE UNDER THE CONTROL
AND ON THE LOCATION OF THE I WAS
ON THE MASTER EMPLOYER WHICH IS
KIND OF OFFENSIVE.
DIDN'T YOU KNOW THE EMPLOYER
CONTRACTOR --
SO I I I I I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS I I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE WARRANTED IN THIS IN THIS
ASPECT I WOULD SAY THIS.
IF I WAS CYNICAL I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THESE BIG COMPANIES ARE --
TIME AND TIME AGAIN TRYING TO
FIND WAYS TO LESSEN THEIR OWN
LIABILITY FOR THEIR WHAT ARE
ESSENTIALLY THEIR OWN WORKERS.
AND WE'VE SEEN IT.
WITH WAGES WE'VE SEEN IT WITH
WORKERS COMPENSATION WERE SEEN
IT WAS SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SO
WE DO FEEL LIKE WE'RE PLAYING
WHACK A MOLE YOU KNOW IN TRYING
TO GET EMPLOYERS TAKE THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT IS
RIGHTFULLY THEIRS THAT WE SAY IS
A STATE SHOULD RIGHTFULLY BE
THEIRS.
AND NOT TO AVOID INCREASE
LOOPHOLES --
BITE BY CONTRACTING OUT.
IT MAY JUST BE INCIDENTAL IT
MIGHT NOT BE A BUSINESS PRACTICE
BUT I GUESS WE'LL LEAVE THAT UP
TO THE EMPLOYERS TO TO TELL US --
I DON'T WANNA ASSERT ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER BUT BUT IT IT'S
HAPPENING AND IT'S HAPPENING
TIME AND TIME AGAIN AND SO --
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
WORKER ALL WORKERS ARE SAFEAND
BECAUSE OF THIS TYPE OF
EMPLOYMENT SITUATION YOU NOT
ONLY HAVE WORKERS WHO NORMALLY.
WOULD BE IN A VULNERABLE
POSITION BECAUSE IT'S SERVICE
WORK BECAUSE IT'S OCCUPIED
LARGELY BY WOMEN WITH WOMEN OF
COLOR --
IMMIGRANTS AS LOWER PAID WORKERS
OUT OF SINGLE MOMS A LOT OF TIME
IT ARE ALREADY WORD AFFORDABLE
SPOT BUT THEN YOU'RE ADDING ONE
MORE TO THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SUBCONTRACTOR OFTEN NOT
UNIONIZED OFTEN NOT --
HAVE A VOICE TO WORK AND SO I
THINK IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY
SAY HEY AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS AND
HOW DO WE MAKE VICTIMS HOLE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
SO -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO
PASS TO JUDICIARY.
IN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE PAST TWO J. SHERRY KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CREO.
CARILLO I DEEP.
NOT FORTY THIEVES NOT VOTING.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I BONTA
REBUS.
LIST ON CALL.
THE BILL DOES ON CALLS WILL WAIT
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
BEFORE WE GET A TERMINATION ON
THE BILL.
AND AGAIN SANCHEZ THANK YOU
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE
SURELY --
AND THEN WE'LL GO ON TO AB.
ONE SEVENTY ONE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS.
IT'S AGAIN --
THIS WAS PART OF A LAST YEAR AND
HAS BEEN PULLED APART --
IN ORDER TO INSURE --
THAT WOMEN IN PARTICULAR BUT ALL
WORKERS ARE SAFE ON THE JOB IT'S
NO SECRET IN SPITE OF THE GREAT
STRIDES WE'VE MADE OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS SEXUAL HARASSMENT
WORKPLACE REMAINS A PERVASIVE
ISSUE ACROSS INDUSTRIES.
ESTIMATED 25280% WOMEN
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
WORKPLACE AND IT'S NO SURPRISE
THOSE NUMBERS GO UP OVER TALK
ABOUT WOMEN COLOR IMMIGRANT
WOMEN AND WOMEN IN LOW WAGE JOBS.
AT THE SAME TIME APPROXIMATELY
60% WORKERS WHO EXPERIENCE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE WORKPLACE
NEVER REPORTED.
THE REASON OVERWHELMINGLY CITED
FOR THIS IS FEAR AND I THINK WE
HEARD IT EARLIER WITH --
WITH MISS RACES.
AS THAT HURT.
HER WORKER TESTIMONY IT'S FEAR
OF LOSING YOUR JOB IT'S FEAR OF
LOSING YOUR HOURS IT'S FEAR
BEING LAID OFF ITS FEAR OF BEING
ABLE SUPPORT YOUR FAMILY FARE
IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCES TIED TO
LOSING A JOB.
SO RETALIATION INTAKE FORMS IN
SO MANY WAYS AND OFTEN WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR ARE ON REALLY CHILLED
FROM FROM ESTABLISHING THE
RIGHTS.
ALTHOUGH THEIR RIGHTS FOR WOMEN
WHO CAN HIRE AN ATTORNEY AND SUE
UNDER FOR YOU HAD THE RIGHT FOR
A WOMAN.
TO CHANGE THE SITUATION WITHOUT
FILING A LAWSUIT --
IS VERY LIMITED IN FACT IT
DOESN'T EXIST AB ONE SEVENTY ONE
PROTECTS VICTIMS OF WORKPLACE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT SOLVE BY
GIVING THESE WORKERS THAT SHE'LL
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO COME
FORWARD.
IT WOULD ESTABLISH A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION WITHIN NINETY DAYS
OF EMPLOYERS KNOWLEDGE OF THE
VICTIM STATUS.
I'M SO OF COURSE THE EMPLOYER
WOULD HAVE TO KNOW IN BEEN
INFORMED A SUPERVISOR WOULD HAVE
BEEN TOLD THAT THIS HAPPENED AND
AND THEN NONETHELESS AT CREATED
ACTIONS WHICH PUT THE WORK IN A
WEBER SPOT.
THE NUMBER ONE THING WE HEARD WE
ACTUALLY THIS BILL CAME OUT OF
DOING HEARINGS ACROSS THE STATE
AND WHAT WE HEARD THE MOST WAS --
AS A SITUATION THAT YOU CAN
IMAGINE A RESTAURANT WHERE A
SERVER OR OR A DISHWASHER GOES
TO TELL --
HER SUPERVISOR LIKE LOOK THE
COOK IS PENSION MY BAT SERIOUSLY
WAS WHAT WE HEARD MULTIPLE TIMES
I DON'T WANT TO WORK WITH THAT
CC.
AND THE SUPERVISOR SAID OKAY
THEN I'M CHANGING YOUR SHIFT.
THAT'S RETALIATION AND AND NO
WOMAN SHOULD HAVE TO FILE A
LAWSUIT IN ORDER TO STOP THAT
BEHAVIOR THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
FACE THE CONSEQUENCES SOMEBODY
ELSE'S ACTIONS --
THIS WOULD ENSURE ON THAT THEY
HAD THESE RIGHTS IN THAT IT WAS
OF COURSE REBUTTABLE I KNOW THE
OPPOSITION WILL COME AND SAY AS
THEY DID IN THEIR LETTER.
THAT SOMEBODY STOLE FROM THE
WORKPLACE --
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY THEY ALSO
FILED A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS NOT A FORMAL
COMPLAINT BUT SAID COMPLAIN THEY
CAN BE FIRED THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
NOT TRUE.
YOU ALWAYS CAN BE FIRED IF
YOU'VE STOLEN FROM YOUR
WORKPLACE --
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF BEING
A READ THE ALL THIS DOES HAVE TO
ACTUALLY HAVE A REASON TO FIRE
OR TO CHANGE SOMEBODY SCHEDULE
OR TO REDUCE THEIR HOURS THAT
THAT IS --
ARTICULATE YOU CAN ARTICULATED
IN IT SAID NOT BASED ON THE
FACTION SO --
WITH THAT I THINK CAN VEGAS MY
THANK YOU WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
AND TODAY MORE THAN EVER I AM
REMINDED THAT THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEE IS THE BEST COMMITTEE
AND THE BUILDING BECAUSE YOU
HEAR THROUGH THE COMBINATION OF
BILLS.
AND TESTIMONY YOU REALLY GET A
SENSE OF WHAT IT IS TO BE A
WORKER IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT WORKERS FACE AND
I FEEL LIKE ANY ONE OF THESE
BILLS GIVES YOU A LITTLE PIECE
OF IT.
BUT TOGETHER THE BILLS THAT YOU
HEARD TODAY REALLY CREATE A
PORTRAIT OF WHY IT IS SO HARD TO
STOP SEXUAL HARASSMENT ON THE
JOB.
PARTICULARLY OF LOW WAGE WORKERS.
THIS BILL I BELIEVE IS AT THE
HEART OF SOUL MUCH OF THE
PROBLEM.
WHEN WORKERS REPORT VIOLATIONS
THEY GET RETALIATED AGAINST
ALMOST EVERY TIME HAVING BEEN A
UNION REP HI I AM A LABOR LAWYER
WHEN YOU TALK TO WORKERS?
EVERY SINGLE TIME THEY REPORT
VIOLATIONS THERE IS SOME FORM OF
RETALIATION IT IS EXTREMELY
WIDESPREAD AND IT IS THE BIGGEST
REASON THAT WORKERS DON'T REPORT
ABUSE.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS IT
WOULD SAY OKAY IF YOU REPORT
THAT YOU ARE SEXUALLY HARASSED
AND THE NEXT DAY OR FIRED OR THE
NEXT WEEK YOU'RE FIRED OR YOU'RE
PUT ON THE NIGHT SHIFT OR YOU
GET YOUR HOURS CUT?
WORKING ASSUME THERE WAS A
CONNECTION BETWEEN THOSE TWO
THINGS NOW IF THE EMPLOYER HAS A
GOOD REASON ALL THEY HAVE TO DO
IS COME AND PRESENT IT.
THE EMPLOYER AS AS I THINK WE'VE
WITNESS TESTIMONY.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WOMEN WHO
HAVE BEEN TRAUMATIZED TO OUR IN
WORKED SITUATIONS WHERE THEY
HAVE VERY LITTLE POWER VERY
LITTLE VOICE VERY LITTLE
RECOURSE. TO ASK OF THEM TO BE
ABLE TO THEN PROVE THAT THE
ACTIONS THE EMPLOYERS TOOK TO
PUNISH THEM FOR SPEAKING OUT WAS
RETALIATORY MET SOME STANDARD OF
RETALIATION.
IS -- NOT
ONLY UNFAIR IT'S UNREALISTIC IT
CANNOT HAPPEN THE WORKERS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE EVIDENCE TO
SHOW RETALIATION THE EMPLOYERS
ACTUALLY DO HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
EVIDENCE SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
SOMEBODY.
PUTS FORTH THE CLAIM AND THEN
THEY GET FIRED AND EMPLOYERS AS
IT WAS BAD ATTENDANCE THEY HAVE
THE RECORDS TO PROVE THAT IT IS
MUCH EASIER FOR THEM TO SHOW.
THAT SOMEONE DOESN'T DESERVE
THAT LEVEL OF PROTECTION THEN
FOR ONE OF THESE WORKERS WHO HAS
ALREADY BEEN VICTIMIZED AND
TRAUMATIZED TO THEN BE ASKED TO
PROVE THEY DON'T DESERVE TO FACE
RETALIATION.
I'M IN RESPONSE TO THAT
ALLEGATION SO FOR THOSE REASONS
FOR HER INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ALSO SUPPORT.
MANY EVENTS AND ON BEHALF OF
WORK EQUITY AND MJ BENSON
CONSULTING.
WHEN AB CELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT?
DOES THE CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
WHATEVER OUR O. S. C. I. E. S.
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
ALSO THE TEAMSTERS AND THE
CONSUMER JOURNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
STEP OUT TO ME DOING FOR THEM.
THANK YOU --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON LARA CURTIS AT
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCEOF WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSE POSITION ON AB.
ONE SEVENTY ONE THE BIGGEST
CONCERN WITH THE BILL IS THAT
RETALIATION ASIDE FROM THE
REDOUBTABLE PRESUMPTION BUT
RETALIATION FOR FILING A
HARASSMENT COMPLAINT
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINT IS
ALREADY PROTECTED UNDER THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT IT IS
UNLAWFUL FOR AN EMPLOYER TO
CURRENTLY.
RETALIATE AGAINST SOMEONE THE
FILES A SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIM
AND SO THIS IS ALREADY PROTECTED
UNDER THE LAW --
BUT THIS INSTEAD OF AMEND
REVISIONS IN THE GOVERNMENT CODE
AND NOW PLACES IT IN THE LABOR
CODE SO NOW YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
BEEN THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
POTENTIALLY COMING OUT WITH THE
SPECIFICATIONS OF REGULATIONS OR
SOMETHING ON THAT AND THEN YOU
ALSO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AND THAT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING COUNCIL
WITH THESE POTENTIAL REGULATIONS --
ON RETALIATION GENERALLY AND SO
THAT'S OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE
THE PROVISIONS.
REGARDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT ARE
MISPLACED AND THAT THEY SHOULD
YOU KNOW --
RETALIATION AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TO REMAIN WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE AND AND AS MS
GONZALEZ --
SAID THERE WAS --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BECAUSE ALL SAID
AB THIRTY ONE OF THEM OUR THIRTY
EIGHTY ONE SORRY WAS HER ON OF A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT BILL THIS TO
PROVISIONS FROM THAT.
AND THE GOVERNOR VETOED THAT
BILL FOR THE REASONS THAT THE
PROVISIONS ARE CONTAINED IN
CURRENT LAN THEREFORE NECESSARY
AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AB FIVE SIX NINE AGAIN TRIED TO
PLAY SOME PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
ALREADY IN THE GOVERNMENT CODE
IN THE LABOR CODE.
AND THE GOVERNOR VETOED SAYING
THESE TYPES OF CLAIMS REMAIN
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING.
AND A SIMILAR MATTER WE FEEL THE
SAME THING ABOUT A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS MUCH DIFFERENT
IT'S VERY BROADLY DEFINED IT'S
NOT SEXUAL ASSAULT IT'S NOT
STOCKING.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WHERE THE
POLICE ARE USUALLY INVOLVED IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS EASILY
IDENTIFIABLE ALL THE TIME IT'S
LEERING IT'S GESTURES IT'S ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
BECOME SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SO DETERMINING WHETHER SOMEONE
IS A VICTIM OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IS MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
DETERMINING SOMEONE WHO IS A
VICTIM OF STALKING SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND ALL THESE OTHER
TYPES OF CRIMES --
AND THANK YOU TO ADDRESS THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT IS A
CONCERN OF OURS --
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE BURDEN
SHIFTING OBVIOUSLY THAT THIS IS
A CLAIM THAT THE EMPLOYEES
BRINGING AND NOW THIS BURDEN
SHIFTS TO THE EMPLOYER IN ORDER
TO PROVE.
THAT IT WASN'T A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION AND AND I DO SAY
THAT THE EXAMPLE THAT'S USED OUR
LETTER WAS A REAL LIFE EXAMPLE
WHEN I WAS LITIGATING THESE
CASES THERE'S ABSOLUTELY ABOUT
EMPLOYERS THERE'S ALSO ABOUT
EMPLOYEES OUT THERE.
SOMEONE DID FILE FALL SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIM SIMPLY TO COVER
UP THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
STEALING FROM THE COMPANY SO THE
THINGS UNFORTUNATELY DO HAPPEN
AND THAT'S WHY IT IS A CONCERN
FOR US.
THANK YOU --
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY FOR THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN STASHED YOUR GROWERS
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS IN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN AG
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS
MATTHEW WELL WESTERN GROWERS
ALSO POST.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE'RE OPPOSED AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A BRIGHT LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
AND SAYS BRING IT BACK.
I BELIEVE EARLIER SOMEONE
CARILLO BETWEEN SIPS OF TEA WAS
TRYING TO MAKE A MOTION
[inaudible]
TO THE BILL.
OKAY WITH THE BILLS ARE SECOND.
SECOND WAS A MEMBER OF BONTA ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
FROM ANY OF THE ABOUT COLLEAGUES
UP HERE --
I'LL JUST SAY THAT ONE THANK YOU --
MISSOURI GONZALEZ FOR BRINGING
THESE BILLS --
FORWARD AND LOOK AT I THINK
WE'VE WE'VE SCREWED UP AS A
SOCIETY GOVERNMENT.
EMPLOYERS.
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES YOU
CAN GO ON AND ON AND ON OVER
REALLY GENERATIONS BUT I THINK
WE'RE FINALLY COMING TO
REALIZATION THAT WE REALLY
SCREWED UP AS IT APPLIES TO
PROTECTING VICTIMS --
BY WAS A BY THE SIX BILLS TODAY
I THINK PLAY A ROLE IN US NOT
JUST SAYING WE'RE SORRY BUT
TAKING ACTION.
ACTUALLY ABOVE EMPOWER VICTIMS
TO BE PROTECTED OF FRANKLY HELP
EMPLOYERS DO A BETTER JOB
PROTECTING THEM BY A AND SO I
THINK THAT WE ALL WANT THE SAME
THING --
THERE MAY BE DIFFERENT OPINIONS
AS THAT PUTS YOU BRING THIS BILL
FORD AS WELL AS THE OTHER BILLS
YOU BOUGHT FOR IT --
THIS AFTERNOON THE REASON I
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR --
AND WE'D LIKE TO CLOSE I WENT
AND I I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE GOVERNMENT CODE IN
THE LABOR CODE IN THIS IS AN ON
GOING OBVIOUSLY --
WHEN CONVENIENT THE DISCUSSION
THAT'S BROUGHT UP BY THE CHAMBER
WHEN WE HAVE THINGS THE LABOR
BECAUSE OF LONG IN THE LABOR
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE THAT AS
WELL BECAUSE?
IT MIGHT BE SUBJECT TO PRAGUE A
THEY DON'T LIKE LAWSUITS THROUGH
FEE HER BUT YOU KNOW SO WHATEVER
WHEREVER WE PUT THIS THERE'S
ALWAYS AN ISSUE.
BUT I WANT TO BE VERY SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHY WE PUT IT IN THE LABOR
CODE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WOMEN
WHO DON'T WANT TO FILE A LAWSUIT.
A BY AND FAR. EIGHT THERE'S A
CLASS ISSUE GOING ON HERE RIGHT
IF I'M IF I'M SEXUALLY HARASSED
AT WORK I'M AN ATTORNEY I CAN GO
FIND IT I KNOW THE PROCESS I
KNOW THE LAW I CAN GO FIND AN
ATTORNEY.
BUT MOST WORKERS AREN'T EVEN
THINKING THAT WAY ALL OTHER
THINKING AS I WANT THIS BEHAVIOR
TO STOP.
I WANT THIS BEHAVIOR STOP IN THE
ANSWER SHOULD NOT BE FROM
SUPERVISORS AND OUR EMPLOYERS
THAT IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO
FILE A FORMAL COMPLAINT THROUGH
FIFA.
THAT NO WE IN FACT WILL MAKE IT
STOP BY MAKING YOU GO AWAY.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING THAT'S
THE REALITY OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND TO SUGGEST THAT THE VERY
VERY RARE CASES WHERE SOMEBODY
WOULD FILE A FALSE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIM THAT WE KNOW
BYE BYE.
THE NUMBERS IS SO VERY RARE FROM
THERE AND PLAY OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO FIRE THAT EMPLOYEE
IT'S A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
PEOPLE ARE NOT PROTECTED FROM
BAD BEHAVIOR BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
RARE ONE WHO --
WHO BASICALLY ENGAGES IN AND
FALSE REPORTING IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN A LOT WE SHOULDN'T OF?
WE SHOULDN'T STOP GOOD LAWS FROM
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF THAT ONE
SITUATION WHAT WE DO KNOW.
IS THESE WORKERS WHO WHO DON'T
WANT TO FILE A LAWSUIT WHO DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY OR
UNDERSTANDING OR OR DESIRE IN
ANY WAY TO SUETHEIR EMPLOYER
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO BE SUBJECT TO
THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT
HERE SO I RESPECT LAST.
NIGHT ABOUT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION DO
PASSED TO JUDICIARY --
FROM THIS NUMBER CARILLO SECOND
BY SUMMER BONTA CALL THE VOTE.
DO PASSED TO GESTURE KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CARILLO.
CARILLO I DEEP.
HI.
DEEP I GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I
BONTA.
BONTA I READ THIS.
REVERSE HI PHYLLIS WITH THOSE
OUT -- AND
WE DO HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL
WHICH IS AB ONE AB ONE SEVENTY
FOR SOME RETURNS ALL US CAN BE
PLEASE A CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
APPS MEMBERS.
ABSENT MEMBERS ON AB ONE SEVENTY
BONTA.
BONTA I REQUEST.
REVERSE I BELIEVE THAT THOSE OUT
AND IF WE CAN RETURN TO FIRST OF
ALL THE COMMITTEE RULES.
THE THE PERSON THE A YEAH DOCTOR
ADOPTABLE COMMITTEE RULES FOR
THOSE THAT WERE ABSENT.
ABSENT MEMBERS DEEP.
HI DEEP I COULDN'T SALAS
[inaudible]
A BONTA.
ON A REVERSE --
ADAM IN AND OUT IT WAS THE SORT
OF THAT ON SMARTER TIME THEM.
AB NINE ABSENT MEMBER BONTA.
BONTA HI.
AB FIFTY ONE ABSENT MEMBERS DEEP.
A NOT FORTY DEEP NOT VOTING.
BONTA.
BONTA HI.
AB TWO OH THREE ABSENT MEMBER
BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA HI.
AB THREE THREE THREE ABSENT
MEMBER BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA HI.
I AND THE BEFORE WE CLOSE THIS
ONE OF THANK SOME FOR BONTA FOR
SERVING IN THE TODAY FOR SOME
REVENGE JONES SAWYER.
AND I ALSO --
AND I DO WANT --
TO TO CONGRATULATE OUR NEW CHIEF
CONSULTANT MAKE ELAINE --
WAS JUST ELEVATED NUMBER EXCITED
TO HAVE A NUMBER OF THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH RETURN